welcome to this video playing abbasid
ramadhar isn't that just for all if i'm
not mistaken yep so I went in to know
haha great mouth slip I wanted to go g6
that's crazy okay um yes hey so um let's
hope I'm surviving this oh my god so at
least I've got a bishop town maybe this
45 that might be somewhat playable
somewhat check oh wow check what a crazy
game that looks like to complete morons
playing yeah I'm playing her sick that
he's blundering e5 oh wow okay I'm going
back I mean he has excellent development
so he didn't plan that born sacrifice
but it is Sir kind of it's interesting
because of my absolute non-development
ok five yeah this is what you have to do
play with utmost aggression against this
kind of nonsense that I did
yeah I know I don't really think it's
working to be honest oh ok I was I was
only thinking about um rook cheeks and
sorry at Bishop cheeks I'm sorry um ok
why would you take with the rook
we should afford possibly
yeah what at least has very substantial
practical chances in the bloodshed in a
blitz cam maybe it's also enough
objectively but it's it's hard to say
that I don't believe anymore that should
be good now for black yeah okay that's
not working it's not working at all but
again as I said practical chances are
our them 94 queen of six kings ii 8i
takes on your phone hmm it's a whole
look though it shouldn't really work
Queenie 5 zooms what am I happy I'm a
piece up right
yeah this is pieces promised stronger
queen bees queen bee three kings seven
okay at the time I've played against him
a number of times and the score is just
fifty percent even though I was winning
in all games he normally just many
strategical were strategically risky
decisions but he's kind of good at
muddying the waters when he is totally
lost so it's the second of the position
for him here we're now on 96 maybe
interest here right
I 92 was good for Queen afore may be
okay but I'm I don't want to fall on
even more behind okay
96 king of eight
Group you baby that trade some stuff
I get night f7 in and 95 that it's
absolutely over
time wording that's unfortunate really
but that rook endgame is really good so
I don't mind it
my rook is nicely protecting the Queen
side and blocking the King check
oh I forgot about that move toward Lee
ah awkward
check
okay yeah I played it Jack badly from a
tactic I call a technical point of view
white resign ultimately one now I
completely forgot about Rupert e6 of
course I don't have to give him the c6
pawn I can just play whatever and win
just not allowing to take no I mean I
know even taking me five is winning okay
so of course he he got far more than he
then he should have yeah he ran on
Castle that strong medicine but ok in
blitz chess certainly doable it's not
enough it's really not enough but it is
it's always tricky of course now the
engine wants to take I suspected that
this means but I wasn't entirely sure I
was thinking it this might be a move but
that census it's already mistake fishery
six is good we are probably like eight
Queen FIM and black wins but I think
this was not bad right here here now I
have no g2 I saw that too late that's
much stronger it's a tempo in the Queen
and Queen has to move and in many cases
i can even trade ya like this I'm just
happily trading here and and will win
easily okay that's also winning but
check more complicated this is this and
now I'm here f5 now I make a mistake
here with this screen before i have to
go here that wins just flat-out wins now
i can take here because the King can
recapture on his own so that that was
the real deal here i'm completely
winning after King sm
and this is yeah then I have to still
have to play that that Rogaine came
which actually I believe also wins but
of course a piss-up would have been much
much simpler okay well thanks for
watching